همم هذا هو قال السبرينا سينج نائبه
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
بلادها لن تخفض مخزوناتها من الاسلحه الى
مدون مستويات معينه فيما ترسله من مساعدات
لاوكرانيا واضافت سينغ ان الولايات
المتحده تحافظ على مستوى جاهزيتها الذي
يحفظ شعورها بالامان
نيه نرسلها لاوكرانيا نعيم دائما مدى
استعدادنا لن نخفض مخزوناتنا الى ما دون
مستويات معينه وسنحافظ على مستوى
استعدادنا الخاص الذي يشعرنا بالامان فيما
يخص استعدادنا في شرح اسيا نشعر بثقه اننا
قادرون على الاستمرار في تزويد اوكرانيا
بما تحتاجه من مساعدات امنيه مع التركيز
على مناطق اخرى في المحيطين الهندي
والحادث وبالتاكيد نواصلوا التركيز على
الصين وهو ما جاء ذكره على نطاق واسع في
استراتيجيتنا للدفاع الوطني